[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
make it work
thank you very much welcome to Comic Con
we have an amazing show for you tonight
this is our third year yes here third
year here let me start by promising that
tonight there will be no edge here in
cameo
of course I'm talking about Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones returned on
Sunday fans were upset that there was a
cameo by Ed Sheeran yes yes
even worse next week's episode of Game
of Thrones is called the Bieber ring a
good sign as you know I was at Comic Con
last year and last you last year there
were a bunch of movies about a dreary
dystopian future yeah
turns out they were documentaries don't
applaud that one we're really screwed
right now lots of special events taking
place in honor of Comic Con yesterday at
the San Diego library there was a
Quidditch tournament yes yes and trust
me when a bunch of adults get together
to play Quidditch there are no winners
there were people I'm sorry there was a
whole section that was so happy right
now
right now they're hiding their broom I
know sliding them under it's expensive
to be here isn't it expensive it is
expensive yeah this is an interesting
fact the average cost to attend Comic
Con is 1603 dollars yeah which
coincidentally is the exact amount of
money that transformers took in last
weekend
I just turned into a Chevrolet right
there yeah by the way I got to mention
this in the new Transformers five they
open with the Transformers in the
distant past I don't know if you saw
that yeah distant past unfortunately not
far enough in the past to stop the
meeting where they decided to make
Transformers fire it was the only flaw
you